The teaser trailer for Mary Poppins Returns
just dropped with a sugary dose of nostalgia
and a first look at the magical nanny played
by Emily Blunt.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and this is my teaser trailer breakdown for
the Mary Poppins sequel where I'll be explaining
some cool easter eggs and other details you
might have missed.
And be sure to let me know in the comments
about anything you spotted too!
It looks like Oscar-winning costume designer
Sandy Powell has done a wonderful job with
the characters' costumes.
In fact, the new film includes an easter egg
to the original movie in the form of the robin
on Mary Poppins' hat.
That little decorative bird is a call-back
to the robin which featured in the song A
Spoonful of Sugar and which accompanied Mary
as she sang to the Banks children about how
to tidy up their room.
And the new teaser trailer also includes another
tribute to that famous song in the scene where
Emily Blunt's Mary admires her reflection
in the mirror before walking away, only for
her reflection to stay behind, watching and
raising an eyebrow as Mary leaves.
That's a throwback to the mirror which Julie
Andrews' Mary took out of her carpet bag and
put on the wall in the Banks family's home.
And when she was readying to leave the house,
putting on her hat and coat in front of that
mirror, her reflection took on a life of its
own and joined her in singing A Spoonful of
Sugar, before watching Mary leave and then
winking!
And if you look carefully, you can see this
movie's version of Mary's parrot-head umbrella,
which, apparently is going to be able to talk,
just like it did in the first film.
"And if you think I'm keeping my mouth shut..."
"That will be quite enough, thank you."
Of course, the sequel is returning to Cherry
Tree Lane and, once again, we'll be meeting
the Banks's neighbour Admiral Boom, whose
ship-inspired home has been updated for the
new movie.
The filmmakers have explained that although
the sequel is not going to be an exact reproduction,
it will have familiar elements from the first
film.
In fact, according to the movie's production
designer, "[they] want [us] to feel like [we're]
seeing something [we've] seen before, but
[we're] really seeing it for the first time."
As well as Admiral Boom, Mr Binnacle is also
returning for the sequel, though they'll both
be played by new actors.
And I wonder if their habit of firing a ship's
cannon twice daily will also be making a come-back?
Also here in the shot of Cherry Tree Lane
is what looks like a Milkman pushing a crate
of milk bottles.
The Milkman is a new character for the sequel
and appeared in author P.L.
Travers book, Mary Poppins Opens The Door.
And just as Admiral Boom's house in Cherry
Tree Lane draws on the one in the 1964 classic
without being exactly the same, so too the
kite we see in the trailer is clearly inspired
by the green kite with a yellow trim which
belonged to the Banks children in the original
film.
And like that original kite, the one in the
new film has clippings from the Times newspaper
on it and its tail is also made from one of
the 'Votes for Women' sashes worn by Mrs Banks.
This shot here also looks like a literal hat
tip to the original Mr Banks as he has a similar
look and, if you remember, in the classic
film Mr Banks had his bowler hat punched through
when he was sacked from the bank just before
he returned home for the "Let's Go Fly A Kite"
song with his children/family.
Now, if you're a little unclear on the movie's
timeline, the sequel takes place 20 or so
years after the original which was set in
1910.
That means Mary Poppins Returns will take
place in 1930s depression-era London.
Michael and Jane are now grown up and Michael
has three children: Georgie, Annabel and John,
who are the three new children we see in the
trailer.
Michael and Jane are obviously delighted to
see Mary Poppins again and, according to the
movie's synopsis, the magical nanny returns
to the Banks family after Michael suffers
a personal loss.
Together with the street lamplighter Jack,
who's played by Lin-Manuel Miranda of Hamilton
and Moana fame, Mary Poppins will use "her
unique magical skills to help the family rediscover
the joy and wonder missing in their lives."
On the subject of fun, if you were concerned
about the rather dark colour palette in the
trailer, then I think this might just be how
the movie sets up the story.
First of all, it's set during the Great Depression,
Michael has lost his wife, and the weather
is literally dark and stormy.
But as we saw in the first film, changes in
the wind signal Mary Poppins coming and going.
And the moment she appears in the teaser,
the sky starts to brighten and we get stronger
colours.
Disney has also released some promo photos
from other scenes that aren't in the trailer
and they give us a good hint of some of the
fun, colourful moments we can look forward
to in the final film.
So, what did you think of the teaser trailer
for Mary Poppins Returns?
And were there any other cool details you
spotted?
Let me know what you thought in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to like,
share and subscribe to get all my new videos!
Plus while you're here, check out more of
my Disney and trailer breakdown videos by
tapping the screen now.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!